ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
عائشه رضي الله عنها
ذا بروفيت صلى الله عليه
ب
رضي الله عنها
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه
عائشه
time was not prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
however tells us great
because her husband our propet
الحافظ ابن حجر ان الفتح في كتاب الفضائل
عائشه رضي الله عنها
صلى الله عليه
‏teaching transmitting articula
of all of
you have all of that
عائشه
رضي الله عنها
unevable
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
and wastical
be so when he passed away because was
desper needed
صلى الله عليه وسلم
wasilable
and her days
and
those seeking
knowledge of the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
and
lived
‏was
and
you
that is
behind the curtain
but these roles that played in the lives
of the
‏by
sister
messengers and props and companions they
could not have reached the levels that
they reached and they could not have
fulfilled
the obligations that they were
commissioned with without these faithful
dutiful women.
عائشه رضي الله عنها
صلى الله عليه
رمضان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ربيع
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلمجره
عليه الصلاه والسلام
ربيع الاول
now عائشه رضي الله عنها
[Silence]
coming from
‏Ging
الاول
عائشه رضي الله عنها هسا
ان اول ما بدئ به رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم من الوحي الرؤيا الصالحه
الصادقه
يراها في المنام ثم تقع كما راها مثل فلق
الصبح
صلى الله عليه
‏withation and initiated with
thatevelation
with pron that would see in sleep go to
sleep see something happening someone
saying something something occurring
someone comingaving and would wake up
would happen exactly as it
continued
الحافظ ابن حجر
mon
time
now
concerning to him could you could you if
every time you put your head down to
sleep you have
عائشه ثم حبب اليه الخلاء فكان يخلو بغار
حراء
ويتزود لذلك الليالي
ويتحنث في غار حراء يعني يتعبد بالتفكر ر
بالتفكر
في وحدانيه الله في خلق الله
يتفكر هذه عبادته اذ كان لا يعلم ما
الصيام
الله سبحانه وتعالى اخبرنا بذلك ان النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم ما كان يدري ما الكتاب
ولا الايمان
قبل وحي
اليه
حراضان
take
[Silence]
his
ابراهيم عليه السلام
حتى جاءه الحق في غار حراء
فاتاه جبريل عليه السلام في صوره رجل
واتاه وقال له اقرا
قال ما انا بقارئ
قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم فاخذني
فغطني
حتى بلغ مني الجهد ما عرف يتنفس
ثم ارسلني فقال اقرا قلت ما انا بقارئ ثم
اخذني الثانيه فغطني حتى بلغ مني الجهد ثم
ارسلني فقال اقرا قلت ما انا بقارئ ثم
اخذن الثالث
لماذا ياخذه كل مره ويغطيه
ياخذه ويغطيه حتى يبلغ منه الجاد حتى يعلم
ان هذا خارج افكاره هذه مش اشباح واوهام
هو يتوهمها اخذني فغطني
صلى الله عليه وسلم جبريل
اقرا lang could
unable to
unl
and he took me and
me until bre and let me go and
اقرا said unable to and took me time and
me until I could breathe I could breath
heed me until I was breathless
and took me let me go said time
and I repe again
and so took me
يقول ابن القيم رحمه
‏this
happ this isn't someination
this isn't some dream some vivid
hallucination
this is another person outside of myself
who is touching meac with me holding me
[Silence]
اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق
خلق الانسان من علق
اقرا وربك الاكرم
الذي علم بالقلم
علم الانسان ما لم يعلم ثم انصرف
الله
سوره الفاتحه
سوره سوره الاخلاص
سوره الكافرون
الكرسي
الله سبحانه وتعالى
இ
‏froming
to ofite
and lord
generous and honorableite
in the name of your lord and he is most
generous
‏the
with
nowes
can
any
‏goes while
Allah
drops
a person goes through
he didn't say that he created the human
‏dirt muday
howam
was
and the finalage the person is created
into which is
the
breathed
of three stages
الانسان من علق
علق جمع علقه
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
wasakر
[Silence]
عليه الصلاه والسلامر
equivalent
breed
into the while
notice that
‏and
so all
and
being
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم as you could
wasied
خديجه رضي الله عنها
زملوني زملوني
وصبوا
من الماء
[Silence]
عليه الصلاه والسلام
‏And when this
and wife without question did this
and was able to
happen
اخبرها
وقال لها اني خشيت على نفسي
يعني ظننت ان هذا موت او هذا انتقام من
الله سبحانه وتعالى
كلا والله لا يخزيك الله ابدا
فانك تكسب المعدوم وتقري الضيف وتصل الرحم
و
تنفق
على المعدوم والفقير
وتعين على نوائب الحق
‏And so her
because
these
was
did so
would never disgrace you.
You keep ties with yourin.
You help those who are unable to help
themselves.
‏Hold your guest in high esteem and
honor your guest and there is not a
single issue of truth except that you
are champion and vangard
Allah would never
disgrace you in that way
and so she took him immediately to her
cousin and her cousin was a man who was
learned
‏Hebrew and also
and was able to translate
the
in
the Arabic langage and vera and he was a
man who had accepted chrtianity at the
time and so she took him to in order
that he may ask him of his knowledge
خديجه عليه السلام
القصص
عليه السلام
عليه السلام القصص
‏sister
name
wasه
قصيed
with not take
‏son
his mother lat
him as infant
his wife
when he went to med as a fugitive at the
time according to the laws of the phras
not according to the laws of Allah his
future wife was the one who pleaded and
interceed on
‏and
took him back
10 years later and because of wife went
to look for that he saw in the distance
on Z
we that these supporting roles Musa عليه
would not have
‏wasy compr
would not been to put him into
sister was out competing with her and
she would not have been there to
overlook and watch over
‏washed
for the
entire country and state and kingdom
made ation
in
not to go to war with
made theion to go with they would have
‏a pitiful humili
but inaded
in her entire kingd into islam and the
people of
have that critical decion to than after
allah for those
we see these critical positions that
these women around the prophets and
messengers and around these great
‏that they
and one of the worraceful
lies that have been told to us in modern
western society today is to scof at
these positions to thumb your nose at
these positions what just a mother just
a mother just a sister just a wife could
you imagine
these are the positions
وى
[Silence]
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا اقول ما
تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم ولسائر
المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم.
الحمد لله رب العالمين والعاقبه للمتقين
ولا عدوان الا على الظالمين واشهد ان لا
اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له هو يتولى
الصالحين واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت
على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم في
العالمين انك حميد مجيد يقول الله تعالى
في كتابه الكريم ولا تتمنوا ما فضل الله
به بعضكم على بعض للرجال نصيب مما اكتسبوا
وللنساء نصيب مما اكتسب
واسال الله من فضله ان الله كان بكل شيء
عليما الله سبحانه وتعالى سوره النساء
‏gend
other gender
for what they created for and for women
cre and ask of
all things اللهم صل على محمد وعلى محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك
حميد مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال
محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال
ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشركين وافضح
النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا
على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه انك لا
تخلف الميعاد ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا للمتقين اماما
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار اللهم انصر اخواننا
المجاهدين المضطه في فلسطين اللهم انصرهم
على عدوهم اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين
المضطه في غزه وجنين ومواضع
فلسطين اللهم انصرهم على هذا الكيان
الصهيون اللعين اللهم اجعلهم على عدوهم
ظاهرين عالين منصورين يا رب العالمين
اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم فانهم لا يعجزونك
اللهم زلزل اركانهم وصدع بنيانهم واقتل
اجنادهم اللهم اقذف في قلوب احيائهم الهلع
والفزع يا رب العالمين واجعل قتلاهم في
النيران واجعل قتلانا وشهدائنا في الجنان
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
استووا واعتدلوا حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا
الفرج
‏Stand shoulder to shoulder. Align your
shoulders and your feet and your ankles
with the shoulders and feet and ankles
of your two neighbors on either side
of you, men and women, straighten their
rows the same. Use the line as a guide
but ultimately align your body and
shoulders with the body and shoulders of
your two neighbors. ‏Straighting the row
is paramount and a huge part of the
reward of our prayer.
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والعصر ان
الانسان
لفي خسر
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالح حات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم بس
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ويل لكل همزه لمزه
الذي جمع مالا
وعددا
يحسب ان ما له
اخلدا
كلا لينبدن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراكما الحطمه
نار الله الموقده
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم
مؤصدا
في عمد
ممددا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر الله استغفر اللهم
انت السلام
just a quick announcement to everyone
thatight
before
soش
at 8:30 so 8 we will
competition
‏up
and 8
in the we
contest for this compe it was a little
under 50 which is very good turn so
if your children
‏Pleas make themight 8
جزاكم الله
علوش
شو اخباركلام
[Silence]
‏K